نحن هنا في الصاله الرياضيه وسط مدينه
عفرين في حلب نرصد لكم هذه هنا عشرات
العائلات التي تشردت جراء تدمير منازلها
وايضا المباني المصدعه جراء هذا الزلزال
كل ما رصدناه في هذا المكان هو قاسم على
الاطفال على كبار على كبار السن ظروف
قاسيه يعانيها سكان هذا المكان نستمع للعم
هنا
نحن صرنا 12 يوم من يوم الزلزال بايتين
بهذه الصاله لا خدمات لا شيء كل شيء
يحققون ماكوره كلها ما في شيء ان عنا شيء
ابدا لا منظمات تجي علينا لا بنشوف شيء
بيعملوا
ونحن انا مريض معي مرض السرطان بالكولون
معي ديسك بنام على ارض مصنوعه على الارض
صار لي 12 يوم بالبرد القاسيه والاجواء
اذا عائله اخرى جميع العائلات هنا لديها
قصص ماساويه قصص مؤلمه عم شو الوضع عندك
الوضع نحن ناجيم الزلزال بس نتفاجئ انه
وقعنا بزنزال اكبر من زلزال كنا فيه انا
زوجتي يا ابن الحلال وقع عليها حيط البيت
كله ولا عشره ايام بالمشفى لحد الان لا
تدفئه تنام عليها المريضه حتى على مستوى
الادويه ادويه ما حدد براعلنا لو كان
بيخلص بيجي على راس عندي اربع اطفال ليكن
موجودين معهم سعله دائمه وعم بيجوا منظمات
طبيه ما قدرنا نحصلنا لحتى علبه الدوله
اذا هي ظروف قاسيه يعيشها سكان هذا المكان
من تشردوا من البيوت وايضا نشاهد هذه
القصص اينما ذهبنا هناك معاناه هناك نقص
بالتغذيه نقص في الخدمات الطبيه نقص في
الماوى هذه الامور رصدناها في كل مكان هنا
والشكوى مستمره والحاجه مستمره لاسعاف هذه
العائلات التي تشردت
والاسراع بجلب المساعدات لهم ولا سيما
للمساعدات عبر الحدود وان كانت المساعدات
قد دخلت بعشرات الشاحنات الا ان مازلنا
نرصد نقص كبير في هذه المساعدات اينما
ذهبنا هنا في شمال غرب سوريا عمر الحوراني
الجزيره من مدينه عفرين حلب